flexi propose un système à l'arrière et
on enlève cette pièce là et on voit que
on a un niveau intégré et le niveau va
nous aider
plus tard on aussi un adhésif ici et on
est des petites pattes ici qui sont à
ressort et ça ça garde l'adhésif à 12,5
mm la surface du mur donc ça colle pas
au mauvais moment
enlevez la photo et ça se fait très
simplement par l'arrière donc la photo
s'enlève facilement on enlève l'adhésif
et là on fait le geste dont 100 vos murs
j'appuie comme ça et le tour est joué
pour l'enlever
le jeu tire et le puits no x et je
l'insère à niveau et arrive au mur si je
veux changer l'orientation le tout seul
se change en une seule ont placé en
moyenne